you recently joined Taylor Swift on
stage that's a big thing with her she
likes to invite other women on stage
with her she's the ultimate kind of
coven group he's the total opposite of
my experience in my in my 20s there was
not a huge amount of Sisterhood it was
pretty patriarchal I'd do these Rock
shows with 500 men and I'd be the one
woman maybe me and Bjork was most of
your audience men uh no it was 50 50.
and and uh like you never invited Joni
Mitchell on stage or somebody uh I
thought I could I would have right um
but no it wasn't there wasn't a big
Kumbaya Sisterhood going on in the way
that I think that you know I don't know
I'm not on the inside of the sisterhoods
here now in this modern time and you did
you ought to know with uh Taylor Swift
right uh yes it makes sense because
she's always writing about her
relationships and guys [ __ ] her over
and here you were riding it you know
probably around her age or maybe a
little younger you were writing about
guys [ __ ] you over you guys have you
guys have something really in common you
really know how to capitalize on that
yeah or just distill it at least that's
right does she ask you for advice if she
was smart I I would think she'd say you
know what Alanis you've been through
this what I'm going through now is very
similar to what you went through does
she sit down with you off stage and say
gee is there anything you can tell me
about this or is she the type that
thinks she has it all underneath well I
don't know about the advice giving thing
but but we definitely had a moment of
mutual validation and just a wink of
holy [ __ ] I mean we didn't say holy [ __ ]
but it was the theme of our interaction
was wow this is not always easy and I
just gave her a lot of love anyone in
the white hot heat for that sustained
amount of time I just got to give him a
hug right and you think she's handling
this well I think she's Built For This
foreign